that was game uh one and uh well Magnus
coming to the board here facing 1v3 in
the first game what was your reaction
well I mean he's played it before
and I mean it's partly meing I I guess
but it's I mean it's a good move so no
big deal is it something um that is
offensive at all to face no of course
not okay good um what did you think of
the first game here um I was really
happy with the opening uh sorry uh I
like these setups for um for black quite
a bit um I think he found
um he found a good plan with Knight B5
and queen E2 but I was also quite happy
with my my reply there and I was really
looking for ways to to fight for an
advantage but I didn't really find them
um and then I miscalculated a bit so I
actually had to to fight for the draw a
little bit but fortunately it was not
too difficult you didn't feel under big
pressure at any at any point there no by
no means maybe there was objectively
pressure but I didn't feel it what can
we expect from game two when you have
the white
pieces I don't know yet um but um I mean
I'll try and win of course sounds good
thank you m